human behavior is the most amazingly
flexible behavior of any animal species
hi I'm Nick Gillespie for recent TV and
today we're talking with john tooby and
leda cosmides of UC santa barbara thanks
for talking to us
you guys are central to evolutionary
discussions of things like anthropology
psychology applications of evolutionary
theory to all aspects of human existence
what's the primary insight that an
evolutionary approach approach brings to
to the table we're particularly
associated with evolutionary psychology
but that connects to all of the social
sciences and humanities because theories
about the design of the human mind are
central to all of those areas and so
were we're asking the question what
kinds of adaptive problems were our
hunter-gatherer ancestors what kinds of
problems did they have to solve well in
order to survive and reproduce in those
environments and what kinds of cognitive
mechanisms would be well designed for
solving them because that it gives you
insights into what to look for in the
human mind the key thing that changes it
from other coaches to psychology is
instead of looking at the mind as a
blank slate we see the mind is full of
very interesting reliably developing
programs species-typical programs that
guide our behavior yeah when you talk
about little programs you started to use
computer metaphors which I'm assuming
when evolutionary psychology or a
precursor sociobiology or whatever
ethology you weren't using that so how
much how much that was the problem they
were talking about selection pressures
and they're talking about behavior but
behavior is generated by programs in
your head and I don't mean it
metaphorically yeah
devices that are designed by natural
selection to process information guide
jokie havior and you evolutionary
psychology focuses on that intermediate
step of what's the structure of those
programs and without understanding that
you just all you can have a sort of
fuzzy relationships between insights
about selection pressures and behavior
as opposed to a real science of the mind
one of the primary differences is the
traditional worldview was the mind with
some
like a tape recorder or a blank slate
general learning system and the model of
human nature was we're just a passive
receptacle and culture and our
environment is downloaded into us
without the mechanisms of the mind
inscribing a particular content of their
role so I mean it's just like a video
camera doesn't describe it just reports
with others so I mean this is kind of
following up on a critique of pure
reason that there are pre-existing
structures or strictures on how we
process information what information we
see and then how we respond to that
that's exactly right
but can I just say I wouldn't hold I
wouldn't call them strictures right
because that presumes that a that a
blank slate mind could learn anything
and it's actually not computationally
possible for a completely mind that was
a completely domain general that
operated uniformly on all contact to
learn anything that's useful and so I
think of these programs as enabling
learning they enable culture so in
sociobiology the the book by EO Wilson
is one of the watershed beginnings of
this kind of broad area of analysis
since then and now while evolutionary
psychology never evolutionary approaches
to all sorts of things are still
contested but they're much more accepted
much more widespread what what explains
that so Ed's book gave the best
evolutionary biology of its time and
although this is not generally known to
social scientists it went on to just
totally conquer the biology journals
it's not called something separate it's
just evolution area biology but that's
not a complete thing so really what
evolutionary psychology is is it's the
intersection of evolutionary biology
with information theory computer science
and then with edit and so that's the
programs are what evolved and then you
have to know the environment in which
they evolved and function and so that's
then the third component of you know
hunter-gatherer studies and primatology
and reconstruction of the pain is it
partly that I mean it's more accepted
now in a way that the idea of the blank
slate of whether it was an anthropology
or psychology has kind of faded because
it doesn't explain enough
there's many things that have made it
made that fade more it still exists but
it's faded the sum has been because of
research and and and theory in the
evolutionary psychology some because of
cognitive neuroscience in cognitive
neuroscience it's becoming clearer and
clearer that many mechanisms are domain
specialized for particular kinds of
problems there's also been we had to do
a lot of debugging of misconceptions
people had a lot of Miss cat if you're
taking an evolutionary approach that
means you must be racist sexist etc when
it doesn't even have it it has to do
with human universals not to do with
things like greys what what does
evolutionary psychology then have to say
if it's saying ok well we're talking
about universal behavior but then you're
also studying variation among
subpopulations what you know where where
does it end especially for libertarians
because we want to believe in a kind of
domain of unrestricted freedom but we
also want to be rooted in an empirical
world that is available through rational
analysis I mean because you're not
saying everything go everything can go
but you're also not saying that
everything is predetermined it's not
universal behaviors it's actually the
genetic developmental basis of the
program's it's universal so and that
that's one of the key things because the
whole point of having a brain is to make
your behavior dependent on information
from your environment so you expect
there to be varying behavior depending
on the environments that you're
encountering and you can't know in
advance what's inevitable and what's not
inevitable socially until you know
something about the design of these
mechanisms just like being nearsighted
doesn't mean you can't see you there's
glasses contact lenses there's laser
surgery why is that true because people
bother to figure out how the eye works
if you understand how a mechanism works
you know how to intervene in some way I
mean it's very important what Lida just
said that human behavior is the most
amazingly flexible behavior of any
animal species right and we don't know
some intrinsic limits about what could
be potentially expressed by people in
the different and in various
environments or differ
interacting but you can't unlock these
potentialities unless you understand the
the circuit logic or the code of the
programs in the head so for example
people tend to ought to automatically
categorize people on the basis of race
and then they found it was very they
couldn't get people to stop doing it it
turns out that from an evolutionary
perspective it would be very unlikely
you'd have a mechanism whose function
was to detect race because you never
would have run into ancestrally there's
somebody from a different race so it had
to be that the program's function was
different okay and we hypothesized that
the program's function was to detect
coalition's and therefore in the modern
world certain kinds of input of alliance
and so on then made race as opposed to
any of the thousands of other dimensions
of human variation a kind of queue - who
would like me to lie with whom and so we
created experiments in which race no
longer predicted coalition in just a few
minutes as you have a lifetime of
experience supposedly of learning race
right but people stopped categorizing by
race in their memory systems and their
sort of implicit ways and that was if
you find the right aspect what's the
what is the feature of the program then
you can start to have make much more
deliberate active progress towards
whatever your social goals are how do
you know when differences are big and
really matter say and when they're
trivial so like you know it's hair color
we would say is trivial I mean it has
meaning but compared to gender or and
not even gender but you know physical
differences among the sexes or between
the sexes how do you how do you figure
that out no so then in any population
I'm assuming that the differences among
women are with with inside the category
of women are as great as they are
between women and men or you know how do
you find out what is salient that well
we don't try to quantify that what we
try to do is and our colleagues try to
do is understand the causal mechanisms
that result in whatever whatever
variation you see around you
gender differences in gender
similarities I mean some mechanisms if
the men men and women ancestrally had
similar adaptive problem to solve you
you don't expect there to be differences
in the mechanisms that solve them it's
when there were adaptive problems like
ones in hunting versus foraging that the
differed by the sexes that's when you
expect to see some differences but you
need to know the structure of the
mechanism involved so colleagues of ours
there had been a hundred years of theory
free research looking at spatial
cognition in humans and people kept
finding a male advantage on certain
kinds of spatial cognition some of our
colleagues thought well what would you
need what kind of spatial cognition
would you need to be a good gather and
they said well you need to remember
where things are in a complex array you
need to be able to plants don't don't
get up and move around but they might
not be fruiting now they might be
footing later so you want to remember
that you want to be able to go straight
to one of those patches and so on and
through a series of experiments from
right from the beginning they found the
first female advantage that any
psychologist had found in spatial
cognition and it's because it's not
because the scientists were male or
female or anything like that
it's because they were starting from a
theory about the adaptive problems our
ancestors faced now once you know
something about the mechanisms that are
governing spatial cognition you can you
you could in principle design math
programs that might make certain types
of mathematical concepts easier to
understand depending on how you in
particular think about it and that
doesn't have to be taught to people on
the basis of their gender because
there's as you said there's a lot of
variation within genders too but if you
understand it that's when you can start
to use it for good one difference
between the blank slate approach is that
you're the basic model of human dignity
is your clay you are passively acted on
by the outside world whereas an
evolutionary psychology model the person
is in a really strong sense inventing
themselves and that that we instead of
just downloading the environment and
becoming what you're told to be and also
it's just in these individual in
prosperous societies with lots of
choices you get this amazing
fluorescence in which people get
together in groups and they very
creatively cuz
rocked a lot of rich diverse ways in
which individuals you know find
themselves and built their identities
and that's that's a very different world
view than the we are passive and have a
key receptacles at first and then or
that everything is fixed ahead of time
that every time
that's the absence of kingly people fear
right but that's not what what's fixed
is the design of the programs but the
programs are themselves designed to be
very flexible well we'll leave it there
I want to thank John to be and leda
cosmides from UCSB talking about
evolutionary psychology today thanks
guys for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie